Muy buenas tardes pues eso es lo que
esperan todos los sindicatos que han
llamado a este día de manifestación
nacional la segunda jornada como usted
bien lo estaba diciendo se espera
efectivamente que haya más de ese millón
de personas que marchó en todo el país
hay más de 250 puntos de concentración
en diferentes ciudades de toda Francia
aquí en París estamos en la plaza de
Italia desde aquí desde donde ya comenzó
a marchar esta protesta son cinco
kilómetros que recorrerán de la capital
Efectivamente es importante que haya esa
presencia lo que hemos podido ver
también es que es una presencia digamos
intergeneracional hemos visto personas
ya asalariadas personas jubiladas que
han venido también en Solidaridad con
las personas que aún están trabajando
también hemos visto estudiantes e
incluso padres de familia que han venido
con sus hijos pequeños todo esto para
pues mostrarse determinados ante los
gobiernos decirles que no van a dejar de
protestar hasta que esta reforma no sea
retirada eso es lo que quieren las
personas que están presentes aquí en
este en esta marcha el día de hoy aquí
en París A sabiendas además de que los
franceses pues temen de que sí haya una
posibilidad de un bloqueo del país en
caso de que este movimiento pues siga
tomando muchísima más fuerza y en ese
caso según un último sondeo cerca del
64% de los franceses culparían al
gobierno del bloqueo del país algo que
ya se vivió en 1995 en esa época también
hubo una serie de huelgas muy
importantes en el todo el país y durante
bastante tiempo así que lo que hemos
visto es que las personas están
determinadas que el gobierno las escuche
y que a pesar de que se ha mostrado
reticente a cambiar esta idea de pasar
de Finalmente pues la edad de la pensión
de 62 a 64 años
para tener una pensión completa pues
van a dejar de estar detrás de de estas
manifestaciones Hasta que el gobierno no
de sobre nosotros